.
JOINING  ME NOW WHO WILL NOT BE
SINGING, BY THINK HE GETS THE
MEANING.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE HERITAGE
FOUNDATION.
I COULD NOT BELIEVE THAT
STATEMENT.
IT WAS INTENTIONAL, ALMOST POLL
TESTED.
>> BEING ONE OF THOSE 0 MILLION
I CAN TELL YOU WE ARE INSULTED.
WE HAVE GONE FROM ONE OF THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL PRESIDENCIES TO
THE WORST PRESIDENCY IN LESS
THAN A YEAR AND A HALF.
SO I CAN TELL YOU THAT PEOPLE
ARE INSULTED, THEY ARE
INFURIATED BY THE HYPERBOLE AND
THEY ARE LOOK FOR PRESIDENT
BIDEN TO BE HALFWAY COMPETENT.
BRIAN: THE BIG STORY WILL BE THE
IMPACT OF OVERTURNING ROE V.
WADE AND THE PROTESTS HAPPENING
AROUND THIS COUNTRY, ESPECIALLY
AT THE HOMES OF THE JUSTICES.
I WOULD SAY THE SAME THING IF
PRO-LIFERS WERE GOING AFTER
LIBERALS IN SOME WAY, SHAPE OR
FORM.
>> IT'S UNCONSCIONABLE THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN DID NOT SPEAK
OUT AGAINST THIS.
THE IMPACT WILL BE MORE HELPFUL
TO THE RIGHT THAN TO THE LEFT.
I KNOW THAT OUR RADICAL LEFTIST
FRIENDS BELIEVE THIS IS GOING TO
DRIVE TURNOUT.
BUT WHAT WE ARE SEEING
QUALITATIVELY AND QUANTITY FAY
TOUGHLY AT HERITAGE, THE AGENDA
ON THE LEFT IS ALSO ALLOWING
PARSE BIRTH ABORTIONS.
THERE IS A BILL FILED IN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY THAT WOULD
ALLOW ABORTIONS UP TO A WEEK
AFTER THE BABY HAS BEEN BORN.
THE MORE OUR SIDE CAN FOCUS ON
THAT, THE MORE OUR SIDE CAN
FOCUS ON THIS.
BRIAN: IT'S GUTTING THE STATES.
AND YOU CAN DECIDE THE.
IT SEEMS LIKE THERE SEEMS TO BE
A GROWING RIFT BETWEEN THE
BUSHES AND THE TRUMPS.
GEORGE W. BUSH IS GOING OUT FOR
BRIAN KEMP IN GEORGIA AS OPPOSED
TO PERDUE FOR TRUMP.
LIZ CHENEY IS BEING PRIMARIED IN
WYOMING AND THEN YOU HAVE A
SITUATION WITH GEORGE P. BUSH IS
RUNNING AGAINST KEN PAXTON.
DOES THAT CONCERN YOU?
>> IT CONCERNS ME THAT THERE IS
A RIFT IN OUR MOVEMENT.
WE HAVE TO GET BACK TO THE
BUSINESS OF TAKING BACK THIS
COUNTRY.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE
CONSERVATIVE MOVEMENT, BRIAN,
WHERE THIS MOVEMENT IS GOING, IF
YOU LOOK AT J.D. VANCE'S WIN IN
OHIO IS A CONSERVATISM THAT'S
HOSTILE TO THE ESTABLISHMENT IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
THEY WANT POLITICIANS TO DO WHAT
THEY SAY THEY ARE GOING TO DO.
THAT'S THE BUSINESS HERITAGE IS
IN.
ULTIMATELY WE ARE FOCUSED ON A
CONCERNING GOVERNING MAJORITY
THAT DOES THE BUSINESS OF THE
PEOPLE WHICH IS TAKE BACK THIS
COUNTRY.
BRIAN: YOU ARE STIFF ARMING
BUSINESS GOING TO BLUNT COLLAR.
REAGAN EMBRACED BIG BUSINESS.
>> REAGAN DID EMBRACE BIG
BUSINESS.
40 YEARS AGO WHEN HE DID SO, BIG
BUSINESS LOVED AMERICA.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE FORTUNE 10
COMPANIES AND THE BIG TECH
COMPANIES THAT AREN'T EVEN
AMERICAN COMPANIES.
IT